欢迎你学习白泽国际站运营实战系统课
同学们,关于店铺诊断
我们刚才已经讲了关于店铺层级的一个维度的进行数据分析
那么现在从店铺维度到产品维度去进行分析
那么我们这一章节主要是讲产品维度这个细分板块去分析
我们之前也讲过关于产品怎么样去优化
怎么样去看数据
这些都讲了
我这里主要就是讲一些思路给到大家
通过这些思路
你能够知道怎么样去判断
怎么样去看这些指标
然后具体的怎么优化的话
我们看我们之前有给过的一些产品优化的一些技巧
那么我们对照的去做就行了
那么这里面的思路主要就是
针对爆品和沉淀的数据比较多的产品
进行细致的分析
我们只需要对这些有数据的产品进行分析
那些数据太少的产品,基本就可以忽略不计了, 因为我们的店铺是由产品的数据给加成的, 那么我们重点的数据都集中在照品, 实力品, 这些产品上面, 所以我们只需要对这些产品进行一个细致的分析就可以了, 那么从我的这个截图里面, 我们来一步步来看这些思路, 第一个就是产品转化效果, 产品转化效果的话, 我们去看一下, 我们最近的产品的, 所有的类目是否,
如果不准确的话那么一定会导致你们最近推广花不出钱或者是说整个店铺的流量下降
为什么会出现这种情况呢
主要由于平台拆分类目
也就是本来你们的产品属于A类目的但是平台拆分把A类目拆分成B和C
你们的产品有些类目可能就不匹配了
或者是说本来是A类目被拆分成之后他来到这个B类目
有可能前期的时候, 它的一个数据权重很低, 所以说就会导致它整体的效果下降, 也就是可能这些爆品啊, 成年数据好的产品, 它的效果就短期内下降, 第二个维度的话, 店铺的产品的结构, 也就是你们店铺里面是否有爆品, 实力品, 新品, 搬托管产品, 同行, 爆款, 款式, 用于店铺流量的承接, 等等这些产品, 如果你的店铺里面, 爆品, 实力优品都很少, 那么你的流量肯定是不稳定的嘛,
另一个就是你的新品也很少,那么这个也是不健康的店铺嘛, 因为如果你新品少的话, 你就很难持续的去挖掘一些
潜力品,把它打造成爆品跟实力品嘛, 如果你这里的产品少了, 那么你后续的产品肯定会越来越少了
如果你想要这样流量增长的状态的话, 那么你一定要找好产品结构的布局, 比如说爆品要有实力有品, 要有新品要持续的去发, 持续的去挖掘
因为我们爆品跟实力品到后面是会掉下来的嘛
也就是说它不可能永久都是实力优品或爆品
它会有生命周期的
那么这个时候我们就需要持续的去挖掘新产品
持续的去迭代
让我们的新产品不断的变成爆品跟实力优品
整个店铺就处于一个动态流量变化的状态
那么这样的店铺才会更加的健康
这种类型的也可以去自己根据自己行业去设置
比如说引流款是什么,跑量款是什么, 利用款是什么, 这个你要大致的知道, 你的工作的倾斜度就很清晰了
第三个就是我们只需要关注三种类型的产品, 其他的产品不需要我们花太多的时间和精力去关注了
比如说我们要关注爆品, 实力品, 新增的产品, 这些什么凝效果产品, 直接下架就可以了
特别是那些什么180天可以直接删去都没有关系, 最主要是这板块
第四个步骤的话,我们要去看产品360里面,具体的产品, 我们这里讲的产品都是针对爆品跟沉淀数据好的产品, 是单品, 单品, 那么对应单品, 我们就来这里细致的分析, 它们每一个产品的访客是否准确, 关键值的曝光, 点击是否准确, 我们的这些产品的价格, 产品页和MOQ, 到底怎么样, 能不能提升我们的转化, 第四个就是我们的对手,
他们的产品是什么类型的,他们的价格起电量都是什么样的
第五个,你看一下这个产品,它的流量来源是哪些局道
看看我们在推广方面,或者是在引流方面,能不能增加它的一个整体的转化
要注意,一个是这些产品是直通车推广的产品的时候
那么你就要细分到对应的直通车计划里面去进行分析
那么详细的对比,参考360跟直通车报告里面的数据进行对比
然后进行优化就可以了, 第五个, 我们要去看一下那些关键词的商机转化率, 有些词它的转化率低, 虽然点击多, 但是对它的排名促进作用是很低的, 所以我们要去重点看一下, 单个关键词, 如果它是高点击的, 那么它的转化率怎么样, 转化率是怎么样的, 如果它点击高, 转化率也高的话, 那么它能够非常快的提升,
这个词的排名,所以说这个一定要重视起来, 第六个就是全店访客的有效性, 我们首先就是要去访客详情里面去看, 访客停留的时长和访客访问的内幕偏好, 以及他们的那些词跟产品是否匹配, 比如说我们的访客时长大多数都是在一到三秒钟之内, 那些客户就直接关闭了这个产品页面, 那么说明访客基本是无效的,
只是被统计在数据里面而已
又比如客户全网搜索偏好前几个关键词都不是跟我们行业相关的
可能这个客户的核心主营产品和你的产品并不是最佳比配的
比如说A这个客户是一个批发商是吧
那么他做的品类是非常多的
做的品类可能是ACD四个品类
那么他主要做ABC这三个品类是重点
那么D这个品类是兼职做的, 但是你们的产品就属于这个D品类
所以说A这个客户并不是你们的大客户, 或者是说并不是你们的重点客户
因为这个品类并不是它的核心品类, 如果你们是做A品类, B品类, C品类
这些肯定就是跟这个客户是最佳匹配的, 所以我们一定要非常重视这个板块
如果你的店铺里面的访客都是1到3秒就跳出的话
那么大概率都是循环很少的
而且这种情况都是无效点击, 花了钱没有这么结果的
这个就是关于产品数据精细化的诊断
就是针对爆品跟整链数据好的产品进行优化就可以了
那么这节课我们就先讲到这里
具体的问题你可以参考的这些去对照者去做一遍
我们下节课再见